thank you
hey everybody and welcome to an
extravagant wild ride with Stevo we have
Lisa Vanderpump are you kidding me come
on who would have thought that Lisa
Vanderpump and Stevo were buddies and I
will tell you we are and man she's not
doing interviews with all of this
Scandal all of this controversy all of
this news around her Empire and her
cheating
TV people man we're the ones who got to
talk to her and we talked to her about
everything so strap on your seat belts
and let's get into it here we go you
want this close-up
um just a little bit I think it should
it should work pretty well
ladies and gentlemen Lisa Vanderpump so
happy to be here with this beautiful bee
Yep this is Wendy from Peru thank you
for rescuing her wow thank you thank you
for being the most elegant uh classy
person to be in our dingy podcast fan
yeah but it's pink lights it's got a dog
I don't need anything else what else is
there I I have to say that I was not
concerned with uh having you in here I I
as elegant as you are I I know you will
get down and dirty with the best of them
hey I think it's a compliment that
should have me in here I love it I love
it and and people uh might find us an
odd pairing but
we're talking about that we're just
talking about that but I mean like when
I got the message Stevo wants you to
this podcast because I had been turning
down press or doing anything because of
what happened on Vanderpump Rules it
kind of kicked off it's at like hundreds
of millions of views literally me in the
last few weeks I said tell sivo for him
I'll do anything well not anything but
you know within that happens of doing
podcasts I love it it does feel like
kind of a juicy time and and thank you
for being here what a nightmare it's
been but you know what we're dealing
with it and uh reality television is
always so unpredictable and as a
producer of that show I've seen the you
know abs and flows and it's really
flowing up babe
this whole situation with the cheating
scandal like yes it's a nightmare
because people's feelings were hurt and
and such but from the lens of a producer
is it not the greatest thing that could
ever happen well obviously you look for
great ratings and it has produced that
but after 11 years and these people kids
they were when they first started
working for me about 14 15 years ago I'm
very emotionally invested in them so I
feel I've been on so many Journeys with
them of course it's fantastic television
but a great at a great price you know I
mean and also it was so unexpected we
weren't filming then you know we weren't
prepared for this and uh you know we've
just shot reunion and it was very very
intense and emotional and I love them
all all that kind of police employables
you know I love them all very much not
as bad
we give money to Peru
um our Vanderpump dog foundation so
thank you for yeah
that Tom Sandoval yes it is gorgeous
is he not I think Ariana might disagree
with you right now
I think it was a piece of [__] in the
reunion right I mean with that said he
is one good looking piece of [__] A lot
of them are I mean they're all beautiful
people I sat down at the reunion and I
looked around and I was just like even
Andy said God you are all so I mean it's
Hollywood so you know a lot of great
looking people come through the door of
restaurants that you know and I employ
them of course in Hollywood it's like
you've got the pick of the letter so to
speak
um but Lala look at her she is
extraordinary looking I mean all the
girls
um they're a great looking bunch and uh
they kind of take advantage of that when
it comes to um getting down and dirty
and naughty yeah
um we asked
artificial intelligence I'm not quite
sure how we went about it but I know
that we did we asked what does Stevo and
Lisa Vanderpump have in common
and shockingly
artificial intelligence said that we
have nothing in common except for
um we have a public profile as
celebrities oh oh [__] I
I with you we've talked about mental
health we've talked about depression
we've talked about work dedication to
work being ambitious a love of dogs I've
saved what is it 3 000 dogs in America
and thousands around the world
um we have a sanctuary in China I know
you're a huge animal Advocate and dog
lover so we have that gotta believe you
were born in England yes you're born in
Wimbledon right yeah I grew up in
England though did you or not I grew up
in five different countries but my
formative years really were in England
right where did you go to school at the
American school in St John's Wood oh wow
my daughter was born in St John's Wood
yeah
yeah where is that in London or like
yeah this is London yeah yeah yeah yeah
kind of did you have a favorite soccer
team when you lived in London
no another thing we have in common we
both got our start in the restaurant
industry
yes I was a busboy
were you any good I was absolutely awful
did you have a wrong food or you just
bust
um actually I started my first thing I
was a dishwasher in a pub in London yeah
and I was that was large that was the
worst slowest dishwasher I think I got
fired after two days you know what my my
kids because they you know they've had a
very privileged life we lived in south
of France for years we had all the
trappings and when they wanted to work
in the restaurant industry they started
washing dishes then they started um you
know bussing tables and they started
running food managing no then it was uh
serving but for five seven years or
whatever just so they understood you
know the industry and now they're kind
of managers and Pandora's gone to kind
of create your own business but I think
it's very very good to start at the
bottom your dog loves me more than yeah
can you see that that is a dog that
knows you've got this right she's just
like I'm home yeah she's she's really uh
so we have a lot in common you guys
we're both on Dancing With the Stars
yeah that was awful
it was so hard I mean I know it's not as
hard as jumping off a mountain or doing
all the ridiculous things that you do
but that was really hard and I was
filming quality show at the time so
doing two shows it was so I lost so much
weight I was shaking all the times I
felt so you know because you'd have to
exercise like six hours a day weren't
you you were because it was so
complicated right
and my experience was that no matter how
many hours I put into rehearsals there
was no way
like I mean I I might as well have not
rehearsed because nothing was going to
help me and how far did you go the first
week I lasted six weeks oh I lasted yeah
a few weeks well and then I fainted him
rehearsal but by then I was I had a
virus I was like weak but yeah I I lost
it quite yeah a few dances but it was it
was very stressful it's uh your body's
not used to doing that right like dance
that many hours a day it's pretty hard
it is really I when people ask me I was
like I don't do it yeah it's and I I was
very surprised to learn that you were on
Dancing With the Stars were you yeah why
what are you saying I want what it's a
subliminal message to that I was just I
was just surprised by it I thought that
I I view it as
uh something that people don't do during
the peak of their career
oh right good point and I wanted to do
it I actually wanted to do it and at
that time I had found upon rules and I
was also on a housewife so I think at
that time they said they'd never have a
housewife because I think there were so
many of them and I was just like yeah
but I'm not just a housewife I'm you
know I have found about rules and they
said okay we'll we'll give it a shot but
I
I thought it was an extraordinary
experience I was hanging on for dear
life every week I felt so emotionally
connected to my dance partner like every
time I looked him it was like you're
gonna save my life just as the music
started but it was really difficult yeah
it was really difficult yeah and what
about The Voice have you uh not the
voice the uh Mass singer have they asked
you to do that it did really
that looks like a scary situation I'm
not a karaoke guy I mean they would be
able to tell so fast that it was you
anyway I wonder yeah you lasted longer
as a dancer than a busboy
that tells me anything
um yeah the more I think about it with
the the Dancing with the Stars
um I I was on it a little bit earlier
for me I had just gotten out of rehab I
was living in a halfway house I was it
was like I was this kind of a
transformation story that really worked
for them and I was terrified of of
um you know getting back into like
working the entertainment industry and
this was just a way of Dipping my toe in
the water that's not dipping your tongue
in the water that is bloody scary
because
when it was like two shows a week did
you do it when it was two shows a week
um because I did it was Monday Tuesday
so you have one less day to rehearse and
another live performance then they would
do the results the next day that was
what it was like it was cheap yeah I
remember being two days how many years
ago did you do it I did it in uh 2009 oh
yeah then it was two days and they were
like getting 20 million I mean it was
pretty intimidating yeah 20 million yeah
I know and so you're absolutely right
where I was saying dip my toe in it it
didn't require me to do anything risky
or or to travel like I could rehearse
right down the street from my little
halfway I think it is risky sorry it was
it was terrible not for you it might be
for anybody else that is risky in in
hindsight it was more pressure than it
made any sense for me to be under yeah
at that early stage of sobriety and I
barely made it through because you'd
want to drink if ever you wanted a drink
you'd want to drink that yeah sure I
absolutely wanted a drink and there were
times I reached out to people saying
like hey I'm not okay really yeah it
reached out to you know mentors in
sobriety I'm not okay and that's what
I'm saying
the pressure the stress the you know
like the the exposure I was just so
afraid I was so exactly so worn down
so scared yeah how much time silver did
you have I I I turned one year sober
during dancing
and I got really good advice actually it
was Lacey Schwimmer oh I know her she's
lovely right is she long ago she she had
dark hair perfect I don't know I know
the name I know the name I think she was
there when I was there yeah I remember I
remember one guy I reached out to gave
me some of the best advice I ever got he
said what was it he said hey he said
he said uh he said I I understand he
says sometimes you're not gonna be okay
and and that's that's fine but when you
don't feel okay
uh the one thing you can do that will
always help is stick a cool copyright
when you have diary
I do not want to not be
not be anybody of people wear a diaper
he said that one thing you can do is
conduct yourself as a gentleman because
uh no matter how bad you feel if if you
do the right thing if you if you're if
you're a gentleman if you're kind if
you're you know then you've got that to
feel good about and that will always
improve how you feel so did you conduct
yourself as a gentleman I'd struggled I
went in and out of it but but just that
that's something that I could really
hang on to yeah yeah for sure
what did you think you took from it in
the end did you think okay because you
basically accomplished so many
extraordinary things in fact I was
watching so many of you recently of
things that you have said I couldn't do
that ah the sunset back down yeah and I
was thinking yeah what you know what
what would make you back out I mean
there's nothing I would do that you've
ever done one I don't have testicles
just you know
maybe maybe I would actually stable
somebody else's to my leg
my husband's I'm sure he deserves it
that sounds like sharing needles
but you know
I'm seeing this thing God I don't know
where you were and you said I don't want
to do this I don't want to do this and I
thought at what point do you get to
where you think okay you know what [__]
it I'm just gonna go for it and you have
like these big wings on yeah and they
threw you off a bridge or something and
to me I would just look at it like I was
gonna die if I was ever gonna be in that
situation I couldn't ever see myself
coming back from that I would either die
of a heart attack on the way down but it
certainly would kill me that that is how
many feet did you drop it was over 200 I
believe over 200 feet but let me ask you
this then what was the difference
between that and when we did it in South
what you did it in South Africa that was
the tallest bridge in the world right
and you guys were like amped to do it
am to do it but I am
was uh deliberate about about facing
this fear I have an unbelievably intense
and irrational fear of roller coasters
bungee jumping are you kidding me well
you wouldn't go on a roller coaster with
me but you jump up a 200 foot mountain
with a pair of wings I'm going to go on
a roller coaster I believe next week
um because we need to
um measure the amount of stress that I'm
going to be under with my wife and I
remember we were driving we were driving
down the coast for Oregon and uh we're
in his uh another van that he had and I
turned a corner too sharp and we were
like a Cliff's Edge but oh God it was on
a freeway and Steve's in the passenger
seat going ah
he just was like strong
screws like me I'm a control freak I
don't want to put my destiny in somebody
else's hands yeah I feel like that every
time I get in the car with Ken but it's
a legitimate fear because he's basically
validated that fear because he's had so
many minor you know reverse into this
rear ending that you know like whereas I
touch wood I mean I've been driving for
like you know 40 years uh since I was
like a teenager and I don't think I've
ever had an accident you know somebody's
running to me so like with Ken I always
see everything before he sees it you
know I'm like oh by the way that was a
stop sign not a suggestion is that
what is it about roller coasters though
that you think they're going to come off
the track or is it just I just don't
like the way it feels let me tell you I
like to feel good and I also like to
look good and I'm guessing we've got
some new listeners because Lisa
Vanderpump is maybe a little bit outside
of my demographic so let me tell
everybody how I go about looking good
and feeling good and it is with my diet
baby I have a cheat code that you need
in your life it's called ag1 from
athletic greens it is the most
comprehensive and convenient not to
mention delicious nutritional supplement
you can get it it's this green powder
you scoop it into a pint of water to
start your day off hydrated and with
every Gap in your diet filled why does
it fill the gas apps because it's loaded
with 75 different vitamins minerals
Whole Foods sourced superfoods
probiotics adaptogens I'm telling you
the list goes on and on and on it's the
best stuff you can put in your body I
swear by it every day that is why I feel
so good and you can get if you go to
athleticgreens.com
Stevo with your first purchase you can
get five convenient comprehensive ag-1
travel packs plus an entire year's
supply of immune boosting Vitamin D it
is a great deal I encourage you to jump
on it and to do so again go to
athleticgreens.com
Stevo now let's get back to it that's
what your stomach but that's it you've
got to feel like that when you jump off
a bridge right but I uh I I don't like
it
it boils down to I think the reality
about me is that I am not an adrenaline
junkie I'm simply an attention [__] oh
I see so it's basically superseded by
the attention when you're doing
something whereas on the roller coaster
nobody's really interested because
you're one of many I get it that's
actually interesting yeah I don't do the
things I do for for enjoyment I do it
for attention well so dancing with stars
you had 20 million sets of eyes on you
then right yeah and I found that like
super uncomfortable too there's like a
paradox about being an attention [__]
where you're you crave the attention but
you also really are intimidated by it
yeah like when I was in school as a you
know a young Schoolboy or whatever in my
you know
when I got up in front of the class to
give a presentation I would be the kid
with this voice really shaking I was so
nervous and I think that's you know I
I'm actually writing a book God help me
Simon Schuster like when is this book
ever gonna read you know arrive and I'm
having because I want to write it myself
which is kind of foolish because now it
needs organizing and I need Segways
because I just kind of basically I've
written 53 000 words and now they've got
to try and put it together and tell me
what we need to make sense of it you
know
um but it's just like some things you
think oh I've got this I can do this and
then it's such a challenge you know and
it's just like discipline trying to get
myself to do that like I'm good spur of
the moment get things done I can do it
you know like designing opening
restaurants doing it but then when
there's something that just I think why
can't I do this why cannot why can't I
finish it you know it's like very very
difficult I've
um published two books have you did you
write them yourself or did you work with
the writer yeah that's what I should
have done I should have done that yeah
and um the the first book came out
in 2011 the second book came out in 2022
and the guy wrote the books with did
nothing but write books in between for
that Whole Decade yeah and on the second
book I asked him is there no now you've
done all these books is there anybody
else who's been more of uh like uh
meticulous like oh you were really well
yeah every word yeah an absolute psycho
yeah I need to like hand it over and
give and I think God you know like I got
to finish this I mean now it's serious I
really actually do have to otherwise
they're gonna tell me to piss off you
know because but it's yeah what is it
about well it's about everything I've
done you know in my life I mean I've
kind of raised two kids being married 40
years I've moved in three countries
opened 35 restaurants have my own
charity uh done 600 episodes of reality
television produced Health now it's all
the different things I've done
it's about
um it's about mental health as well
about how I've dealt with it you know I
lost my brother to Suicide a few years
ago we kind of talked like that it's
about just trying to cope in the world
and things that scare you and things
that you think are insurmountable how we
get over it how we challenge ourselves
um there's just so many things in this
book that really just come from a wealth
of experience and so many people when I
do I do a lot of public appearances
um in terms of like you know Rose like
I'll go and and I'll kind of be at one
of the shops and a thousand people will
show up and they'll be there for hours
and and these people when they get to me
in the line I will not leave till every
single person is hard acknowledged
listened to because I really appreciate
you know even in my restaurant I really
try to do that but it's like all these
people they connect to me on so many
different levels if it's not being an
lgbtq activist you know always being an
advocate I've had gay bars for years
I've always you know I never understood
the Discrimination between two people
and and sexuality and sexual orientation
I just cannot understand how people you
know so many young people are thrown out
on the street they're homeless youth
lgbtq you know so and the suicide I've
worked with suicide prevention travel
hotline prior to my brother you know
committing suicide never thought it
would touch our life ever
um he wasn't lgbtq he wasn't he was you
know been married for years and got two
wonderful sons and so that devastated me
but I meet these people and they talk to
me about dogs because so many people
love our furry friends and they know
that I've saved thousands of dogs and
I'm really passionate about that even
one of my taglines for Bravo was I'm
passionate about dogs just not crazy
about [__] and they said you can't
say that you're not allowed to have the
[__] word in the table and I said but
why not I'm talking about the dogs in
the end they let it go because I said
well I'm not saying anything else I kind
of learned to put my foot down a little
bit with you know like guys
um and then they would kind of connect
to me over marriage things have been
married for so long I adopted my son Max
who gave his skateboard to I said to him
I'm gonna do your podcast I was so
jealous I said well maybe you could sit
in and he's just like no you don't want
me sitting there and be like yeah
um but adoption you know people talk to
me about
um business so I I get so many emotional
connections I think my book's going to
be a little bit about all of that about
what I wish I'd done what I have done
what I would do better and where I feel
I've had a modicum of success yeah my
and this is going to be your second book
I did a cookbook which was so much
easier if anybody's thinking of writing
a book and you'll kind of have had a you
know little small pieces celebrity a
cookbook with a few stories the way to
go so easy to start to do this the 53
000 words I'm still not there yet it's
like when is this I feel like I'm
writing the Bible you know it's like oh
from pieces like when am I going to
finish it and then it kind of gets
pushed to the bottom of the pile but I
will in next couple of months I will
deliver so I'm going to choose to if
you're listening do not be scared I will
deliver at some point it's in the my
second book yeah was uh a book of wisdom
what I've learned from a lifetime of
terrible decisions
really yeah and was it funny or was it
it was in turns funny tragic like
sincere like it was it was it was all of
that what would you say at not putting
you on the spot and like I don't mean
what would you say is one of the most
important things that you've learned
really through this whole experience you
know
absolutely the most important thing I've
learned in my life
is
how crucial it is to identify your
passion
full stop I think that most people's
biggest problem in life is that they
have not identified something about
which they are absolutely I do because
well I agree because I would say find a
job you love then you never have to work
a day in your life you know the
motivation comes from the want because
otherwise it's very difficult to get
yourself you know going and like I love
what I do right I love creating new
restaurants I love the hospitality and
Industry
um I actually love producing reality
television even though sometimes as we
say like now it's been very kind of
emotionally draining just doing the
reunion sitting there for 10 hours and
watching all these motions and and these
people really give it all they don't sit
there in the corner they're kind of I'm
not saying they're trained because
they're not trained at all but they're
kind of people that are good for reality
television of people that really Express
themselves honestly and when you do 10
hours of that and they're all sitting
there there's a lot of honesty a lot to
deal with but yeah I agree with you I do
agree with following your passion and
finding it and tapping into that
um I think one of the things that I feel
that's really important is and we would
just talk about this um in the kitchen I
was talking with Scott you know just
before I came in that I think humility
and I don't mean be humble but really
understanding that you know we're all
human beings we all have and you might
get some success or you might the you
know famous or you might be you know
wealthy from great choices you've made
and everything but still being down to
earth and shine and identifying with
everybody I think it's really really
important and um yeah you know like you
say oh when you get in the truck damn
right I'll get in the [__] truck I'll
drive it across the country you know
what I mean you know what I mean I'm not
that I'm still in there picking up dog
[__] doesn't matter how many people I've
got helping me you know I've got six
dogs it's like
um yeah just always keeping your feet on
the ground and not ever thinking you're
better than anybody else because you're
not you might have more luck you might
have more Talent you're not better than
anybody else and do my podcast I've had
so many incredible people and everybody
had a story to tell and everybody you
know taught me something and I loved
that I love that I love conversation
there's a saying that I heard which I
really really love and it's simple we
are all eyes in the same head
meaning that the like the the concept of
Oneness we are all one like God is God
is everything or God are you religious
not religious spiritual oh I'm religious
yeah I definitely I always think you've
got to believe in something yeah yeah
and and the universe is everything yeah
and all of creation is an exercise in
the universe experiencing itself yeah so
like like we're all Divine because we're
all little pieces of the one big thing
and so you're every bit as Divine as I
am no matter who you are you know when I
met you I mean you're so iconic in your
I mean I can't say genre because there's
nobody else like you really per se but I
just always I was always impressed by
how kind you were and I think that is
more impressive to me and I meet a lot
of people because I have restaurants and
you know especially like in Vegas and
you know open restaurants I I mean a lot
of people that come through and uh I
think often people lose their way a
little bit with success and they think
that defines them and it makes them
Superior and I've seen people with money
listen I don't give a [__] how much
money you've got Because unless you're
gonna bring a bag of it to me a dinner
[__] off I don't need it I don't need an
attitude either you know but you do see
people like that
um they think that it gives them and
it's like I
I have met some people I tell you you'll
never think
Dominica Dolce who Dolce Gabbana right
I remember in fact I might actually see
him Shucks I think but I remember when
he came to my house
and huge brand hugely successful and I
remember he came to my house with his
partner and he came and I remember
saying Dominico what would you like to
drink and he said oh Bella I drink what
you are drinking and I was like oh okay
well yeah sure I've been from Jose give
him glass Rosie so I said uh Dominica
what would you like to eat I eat what
you are eating that and the kindness
how wonderful this person was
it always resonated with me and since
become a great friend and I remember
when Jiggy died he sent this three-piece
suits he knew Ken always used to carry
Jiggy around and Jiggy was kind of
iconic he'd been on hundreds of episodes
a reality television and he'd inspired
the Vanderpump dog foundation and this
three-piece suit arrived for Ken in in
the post and I thought well that's
really unusual for him to send a suit it
was a few weeks after jigya died and
inside the coat and the lining were all
pictures of Jiggy and I thought he has
to be one of the kindest most
considerate and also extremely wealthy
extremely successful but never ever lost
a second of that you know and yeah I've
seen other people have made a lot of
money that just treat people like [__]
treat stuff like [__] and if you if you
want to know somebody's true personality
see how they treat the server in a
restaurant yeah they so you can what is
it you can measure man's worth uh by the
way he treats people who have no
importance yeah actually your server is
really important to you oh yeah wow yeah
crazy yeah
oh and they're dismissive yeah that's a
red flag I dated a girl one time who who
was rude and I I was just completely
turned off yeah put you off yeah for
sure how can you recover from that yeah
I've never even I've never even really
thought about it in terms of like the
the importance of people I just think
that it's a spiritual axiom that the way
we treat others is a reflection of how
we feel about ourselves exactly but
there is there's a lot of Truth and if
you're gonna only be nice to people who
are important yeah yeah they're sure
imagine servant tables and there's like
get over here yeah yeah you know and
like the guy has to do it because it's
he's in the service industry but it's
like it's humiliating yeah yeah tables
for 20 years and it's just it's you yeah
food Runner busboy wow everything and it
was just I'm super grateful I don't have
that problem that uh yeah that that and
sometimes they don't tip so like they
treat you like dog [__] and they don't
tip and you're like yeah yeah my father
said never get in a taxi unless you can
afford to give him a tip you don't
belong in there unless you can afford to
give them a check I learned that from my
father yeah that's great yeah
um
now with my father
uh is he still alive yes to you not my
mother but my father yeah same as me my
mother died recently and my father was
uh quite wildly successful businessman
he was uh
um you know a corporate executive for
American multinational companies and
this is why I grew up in five different
countries because oh my God I could only
imagine when he starts seeing your
antics
yeah yeah for sure and
not many times but there were times when
I floated up the idea of like oh like
you know open up a restaurant and dad
has always been so insistent that the
worst business idea possible
well statistics are against you
must fail within the first three years
yeah and then why is that oh gosh it's
very very challenging and I don't think
it's getting any easier I mean what I'm
loving personally is developing my brand
with Caesars because they just have this
extraordinary body of people and and
Corporation but you know what right at
the top of Caesar's Palace all the
people from the people that own it the
corona family you know it's a public
company but to the managing directors
they are all so kind so nice and it's
just such a pleasure to work with them
and I really enjoy kind of doing that
I've opened in the Paris Casino I think
arguably one of the most beautiful
restaurants in Las Vegas
I did up with my design company founded
pumper lane and then we have another one
in Caesar's Palace and then we're
opening another two with them so far
um but it's much easier for me I come up
with the concept build them out design
everything right down to what the
waiters were you know the the cover of
the check everything I mean do
everything the menu and then they run it
and for me as we're getting older you
know it's a real welcome relief rather
than you know my restaurants in West
Hollywood it's a lot of work it's a real
you know but it wasn't always like that
for you I mean in the beginning I'm sure
you had some failures what went wrong in
the business to not associate me with
failures
and just like Lisa Vanderpump I strive
to be successful as well and I want to
help you become successful by
encouraging you to have your own
thriving Business Online that's right
e-commerce is the way and that way
ladies and gentlemen is called ship
station this is for everybody with
e-commerce operations no matter how
you're selling your stuff if it's on
Amazon
Etsy your own website then doesn't
matter because all of those platforms
can be brought into this easy to use
interface along with all of your
different shippers like FedEx UPS United
States Postal Service and on top of that
they give you the lowest rates possible
rates that are normally for a Fortune
500 companies you get to enjoy super
easy when your order comes in it prints
out the label you slap it on the box and
it's out the door it may makes life so
easy and it helps you be successful like
Lisa Vanderpump and Stevo now to enjoy a
60-day free trial you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo again that is 60 days two months
of hassle-free stress-free shipping with
ship station and they're so sure you're
gonna love it it's a 60-day risk-free
trial so go to shipstation.com use the
promo code Stevo and make ship happen
yeah dude now let's get back to it
I walked away from some like in covid we
walked away from Villa Blanca because
the lease had run out it was just a few
months before the lease was running out
and we said look to the landlord we'll
you know pay you half you know through
covet because we're closed obviously I
said no I want the whole Ram which was
something like eighty thousand dollars
much so bye see ya and then the place is
still uh available three years later he
has you know to you know sometimes you
need to but I mean it's it's when you
start a restaurant now it's going to be
a success no questions asked but it but
wow
were they like that where the first
restaurant you did I think it was much
easier to do uh if you came up with a
great product and a great you know
um location in London there's so many
people walking around if you get it
right you're going to you know you're
going to hit the jackpot and we yeah
we've had a total of something 30
something restaurants in London
um bars clubs uh crazy clubs yeah no
well more wine bars and not really pubs
but we've had like we've had a couple of
crazy clubs that were so avant-garde
even I would be like holy cow you know
in London in that day we own the shadow
Lounge which was one of the most popular
gay bars in London
um so in a way have I seen it all yeah
I've seen it all and then some in some
respects um but yeah I just worked
really hard and I try to kind of check
all the boxes but it's not easy I
wouldn't recommend anybody like your
father who goes in the restaurant
business yeah
um so you've always had the Midas touch
with restaurants I don't know I
I don't know if it's the Midas touch
maybe it's just a lot of hard work and
uh tenacity so to speak but I do think
La is harder because it seems like
everything has to be destination you
don't have the passing trade as much or
people will get on thinking oh that
looks nice they've got to go there you
know it's uh it's a different thing New
York is easier
I haven't tried New York and I like to
only be
um you know a kind of advocate for what
you should do when it comes from a
wealth of experience rather than so I
don't know I've been asked to open in
many many different places over the
years the Vegas should be tough right
Vegas is a fan [__] testing it really
is there's people there's an energy they
want to go out they want a great product
they're going to walk into banapan
papari in Paris and they're going to
feel like they're in France I lived in
France for years and it's beautiful and
you feel immersed in the experience walk
into the cocktail Garden it's like an
oasis so I go with and that's also why
I've never really
created a chain because what's exciting
for me is creating a new project like my
new one that I'm doing I'm not allowed
to say once it's coming up I'm not
allowed to say but I'm not sure yeah
well I'm not allowed to say but my new
projects I haven't announced it yet will
be a total individual concept and I love
that you know yeah
to tomorrow
is this is this truck going to Vegas
because I might be sitting in this seat
yeah we're taking the tour bus oh yeah
what are you gonna do there we got
Arizona and we got Vegas what are you
actually going to do there
um we are recording with the the lead
singer of Tool tomorrow in in Phoenix
and not Phoenix but in Arizona the day
after that we're recording with Steve
Aoki the DJ in Vegas oh right so that's
gonna be fun right yeah yeah so you must
go there and you must go there check it
out in Caesar's Palace it's you and
Gordon Ramsay is that right well not
together right not together but both
have restaurants yeah for sure so does
that make you guys and probably other
Dynamics make you guys better Rivals no
we love each other yeah really great in
fact my new restaurant is going to be
um right next to him as well we really
good good together I think we're polar
opposite in terms of what he does I have
great respect for Gordon I think he's
just genius and I think he's been great
Television over the years
um and he he just I wouldn't try I will
always do my research of what I'm going
to deliver I'm very Ambiance driven you
know he's he looks more like Chef driven
you know you see you know that you're
going to go in there and get the best
beef wellington or you know that kind of
when you're doing a restaurant is the
goal to get a Michelin rate rating oh
God no no not at all the Gordons would
be right that's the reason why he would
start a restaurant no I I don't think so
I think he's pretty commercial but he
wants to deliver a just a great product
you know I love Gordon too yeah he's
great and he's you know he's very
English and he's got that sense of you
know sense of humor I think our sense of
humor is a lot more provocative than
than American humor you know we have to
kind of tone it down a bit well apron
Ricky Gervais he doesn't own anything
goes away go on you know
um
I think in England our humor is kind of
more aggressive you know
but it's not only the humor it's the I
think you guys are more graceful and and
like the men are more like James Bond
the women are like just elegant and
classy and really yeah look at you
you're the most graceful woman I've ever
met in my life Are you seriously I'm
sitting here with my feet out and cross
legs but you have a style about it you
know and it's I love this guy can he
pulled me around
but I mean there is a difference right I
mean it's the accent who can fool you
but it's like oh don't worry about that
darling yeah that's true don't worry
about it can you uh paint a picture of
what it was like opening the very first
restaurant well I met Ken when he had a
wine bar so I met Kim when I was 21
through my brother
um Ken had a wine bar so he was already
just starting to get into the
hospitality business uh but he had this
wine bar extensively to get laid to meet
different women uh to get drunk that's
why he had it there was no business
Acumen that came with that at all then
we opened another one I kind of got
involved with the design and then we
opened another one we had a very famous
restaurant in London called the Pheasant
tree which was a really beautiful
building in Chelsea
so then we built up a chain and we sold
out
um so I don't really I don't ever feel
there was a first one and I did it on my
own because Ken had this initial one but
you know basically as soon as he met me
I shut that [__] down like you know we
were going there it was a business it
was not to get laid and it was not to
get drunk you know because otherwise we
weren't getting married that was it you
know that kind of changed real quick I
kind of and and with the the absence of
a business Acumen was his wine bar is
successful oh yeah yeah it was just
because he was a cool dude yeah yeah and
I think we kind of always look you know
like even if I like had a dinner party
last night
like just casual you know kind of
spontaneous I look for to make a great
Vibe great Ambiance I think you know
when you went into Villa Rosa you feel
the you know I love creating spaces
beautiful spaces they don't have to be
too upscale it can be very down to earth
I mean when you walk into pump for
instance in West Hollywood you know it's
kind of got these old olive trees that
you can you go in like dressed in shorts
you can be however you want to be in it
I don't want to create intimidating
spaces
um
but I love the Ambiance I love the music
I love the lighting I love the flowers I
love creating menus I just I love it all
I really do again I found a passion you
know yeah how do you feel about
um the
how loud a restaurant can be because it
drives me nuts when you can't when you
gotta scream across the table You're
Gonna Hate My restaurant you gotta
scream in my room
do you have like a um is there an area
that isn't quite so loud
when I sat there in pump
um you know my restaurant was Hollywood
which in fact releases coming to the end
now and we're kind of deciding what
we're going to do whether we're going to
go forward or not because honestly to
have four like with Caesars and then to
have three here it's quite a lot you
know running them all at the same time
and with all the other things the
charity dog foundation and my design
business is you know my real passion as
well but when we go into pump I love the
fact that you can sit there and listen
to music and have real Ambiance I love
that you know about it what I don't like
is loud restaurants that it's like the
Acoustics are bad with chatter you know
sometimes you go into restaurants and
all the kind of conversations and
bouncing off the walls I don't like that
at all if it's you know like people are
having a drink and the lighting's great
the music's on I like that I think
people come to our restaurant for
entertainment as much as you know as
much as the food have you ever done
dining in the dark
no you know not a lot of things in the
dark and all that
you walk into a restaurant it's
completely different not some way the
servers are all blind why would you do
that so that because they say that when
you shut off your one sense the other
sense is enhanced and so the food the
food tastes different and more and
better and like all the servers are
blind so they lead you to the table and
I went on I was on a date one time where
was this there is one I have pop-ups uh
they have one in Santa Monica on
Wilshire
and I did it and I and I went in and I
was eating and I got like I got like
panic attack because I was like I can't
see what if there's a fire and I and I
started like getting claustrophobic in
my head and I turned my flashlight on on
my phone and the whole place freaked out
yeah they were they were so pissed but
it was like uh it was a crazy experience
I don't know I don't really fancy that
because I think I think you eat with
your eyes as well you know for me I'm
very very visual I like everything to
take all senses you know I don't want to
just go in and it's not just about the
food it's about the whole experience
exactly and that's why I love like again
working with Caesars because they give
me design kind of carte blanche you know
so I mean we show them what we're gonna
do but my partner Nick Elaine and I we
have these Fantastical ideas and we can
create something beautiful and I think
that is that's the essence of a between
us being in surrounding where you know
all the senses detect and yeah so I'm
very much a visual person so no no
blindfold no eating in the dark no yeah
I I I agree sex in the dark's great when
you've had you know like after all these
years
you're not seeing this again you just
don't go back to memories of what it was
like yeah I like that
um tell us about your design stuff oh I
love it I so lucky it's really funny
because I met my partner
um I walked into he had this showroom
and I walked into the showroom and I
thought okay I've got very diverse taste
I but some people always say oh I can
see it's got your stamp on it but you
know I've had a very modern house I've
had not Deco house I've had an Old
English house I've kind of done all
different styles
and I walked into this showroom and I
ended up talking to Nick my partner and
I said you know what I never say this I
said to him
we and it's kind of strange but I think
people around knew who I was because
there's only about five years ago and I
said we are going to be doing something
together
and I said I don't know what it is but
there's going to be a project we're
going to do together and I'm not sure
what it is so then we ended up meeting
and I put some of his lights in a
restaurant and I thought wow I loved it
and then we talked about designing a
restaurant together
um which was our first one which was the
Caesar's Palace one then we did Tom Tom
which was you know it's a great cocktail
bar and beautiful restaurant I think it
was voted number one cocktail bar in
Southern California beautiful you know
with this moving clock and pieces and
huge trees and so it basically sit down
and think what do we want to create
what's the vibe we're going for and each
one is different and to have somebody
also we make everything so vanderpumper
Lane has a factory so Nick's always like
well if you know he said we're not going
to draw it we're not going to put it
unless we can make it so we really
really think it through
and it's like for me I always have this
craziness in my head and this just drive
to create beautiful spaces but can never
find what I want so now to have a
partner where we can make things is just
it's magic It's Magic like a new bar
we're doing I'm like you can really see
it like this and and can we do it I said
this is what I want it to look like and
he's like okay we're gonna get this
we're gonna get the mold we're gonna you
know do it out of concrete we're gonna
so he facilitates a lot of our dreams
you know and so we work on it together
and it's really just a magical magical
partnership and I love it you know it
really has been a great great experience
we've been together now uh five years
and we're working on two new restaurants
together so yeah so it's not like
designing clothing or no no no I'd like
to design everything if it's just still
I want to design it I love uh visuals as
I say I love design but no this is
purely you know Furniture lighting
architecture yeah and I love doing it so
that's really great that's been a
blessing with the uh the restaurants
that are featured on Vanderpump Rules
yes yeah the cast is
like kind of a weird hybrid of actual
restaurant employees and reality
television personalities yeah is it hard
to keep them
in the capacity of a restaurant employee
did she just say really hard because I
gotta tell you about Bluetooth tablets
they are delicious and they have the
same active ingredient as both Viagra
and Cialis except they only cost a
fraction of the price for my male
listeners let me tell you there's
nothing more important than being really
hard so if
supply of
fly I'm free that is if you use the
promo code Stevo a whole month's supply
of Bluetooth tablets all you pay is five
bucks for shipping plus you sort out
your your prescription very easily with
the online provider at bluetooth.com and
again promo code Stevo gets you a whole
month's supply of Bluetooth tablets
absolutely for free all you gotta pay is
five bucks for shipping and if you're
wondering whether or not that might be a
lot of fun let me assure you it is man
when I chew up my Bluetooth tablet and
then show my girl Lux my my blue time
she screams with excitement because it's
that much fun so go to bluetooth.com use
the promo code Stevo and let's get back
to it
I deserve a medal yes
um well
let me say that reality stars initially
they don't the authenticity and the
magic of vanderbump rules I think really
came from the fact that it was an
authentic group and I think anything you
try to do in reality television is never
going to be as good without the
authenticity so when we started bound
and pump rules I had two or three
hundred people that worked for me but I
had this group that I knew they would go
out with this one they would sleep over
at this house there was like you know
eight of them that really used to kind
of all run around together oh they would
fight and then they wouldn't talk to
each other coming in next to I'd be like
leave it alone just get on with you all
you know do this and do that and they
would like have an argument I remember
you know Andy Cohen came to me and he
said look we're going to give you a
spin-off kind of more about your
business do you want to do about Villa
Blanca and Beverly Hills I was like no
two wholesome don't want to do that so
let me think about it and I thought sir
it's got such a kind of little crazy
bunch of people and it's like family
situation so I sent them a picture and
it wasn't a picture that we you know
fabricated or formulated for the pitch
of just there was a picture of me
sitting in this kind of chair with all
the stuff around me which also looked
like they've just come off the Runway I
mean they're all looking like models you
know
and rather straight away went yeah we
want a green light a Sizzle reel so we
did this Sizzle reel and it was so funny
it was like well this one used to date
this one but now this one is dating that
one but living with this one and this
one you know and it was all kind of
interconnected and they basically said
yes to a show and I knew that there
would be magic in that show because they
were also entwined and when you're
entwined and invested like
um you know in the relationship the
stakes are much higher but you if you
put somebody in here and you don't like
them and you still just you know get out
whatever and you just go but when it's
got this emotional investment of a
friendship that has basically been
cultivated over many years it it was
always there was always a lot I mean
like with you know the whole thing the
trans crash and that just basically
transpired on on Vanderpump Rules you
know Ariana and Tom were together for
nine years
and you know on the show for that long
yes and they both worked for me for
three or four years prior to being on
the show so when you've got those kind
of stakes it's not just like planting
somebody and they bang them and you just
it that's not what the show's about it's
about existing relationships it's about
love affairs it's about frustrations
it's about inappropriate you know
relations as this you know what happened
and it and it's yeah it gets complicated
yeah has anybody gotten um yes
I've done it all I would like with uh
with the fam that the show brought them
didn't did anybody uh
think you know I'm I'm too big of a star
now to be working in the restaurant I'm
gonna go oh well that's you know that
was a natural that Pro I mean most of
them don't work for me in the restaurant
now only a couple of them do like James
will do his DJing but the show I think
people have been watching it from the
start understand
um like I've been a mentor to Tom and
Tom in creating their own restaurant
we're not a restaurant bar uh the last
season which was very frustrating it's
still on now we're only on episode eight
now
um well it'll be later I don't know when
this is gonna end but um
I was saying to them you know what guys
it was so frustrating for them trying to
get organized to open this restaurant
cost twice as much took twice as long as
it always does and I said you know what
you're the only guys I know that
actually want to be in the restaurant
business everybody else I know in the
restaurant business since covid are now
living in Mexico and lying on the beach
I mean I really knew people that just
said forget it we're done we'll never
get through this we're done and left and
you know literally left when they had
three or four restaurants just walked
away wow yeah it was very sad time for
the restaurant business over a hundred
thousand restaurants closed in America
yeah everything's like Postmates now too
yeah but I don't think that's healthy I
think people need to get out and you
know because you see like all these
shops are empty because everybody's
online but you know no I think we need
to live we need to you know yeah we need
to be out and about we need to shop
Touch It Feel It by it you know not just
kind of I think that also can lead to
depression isolation staying home I'm
very proud so we've talked about this
the fight depression because that can
that would be an easy path for me to go
down you know so I work hard I exercise
I need bright light good food to keep
you know on an even Keel what's your
exercise regimen well today I just
showed you my foot my horse ran over my
foot you know I broke my leg in seven
places since I've seen you did you not
know that I did not know that so I have
a Cavalia horse A beautiful white horse
that was retired you know the Cavalia
show where the horses white horses come
on and I want to open the show like as a
guest you know do the carpet and stuff a
years ago like about seven years ago and
I said if ever you have a horse that's
retiring you know could I have him buy
him donate or whatever they said well
actually we do have one coming up I went
to meet her please can I have him please
please please and I'd written for years
but I'd often have precarious sources
you know that would like you know a
little bit dangerous and I was kind of
you know a little more self-protection
now as you get a bit older you know I
wasn't 20 anymore I was thinking I would
love one of these horses they are so
smart so I ended up with this Amazing
Horse and I would ride him twice a week
and he would live about half an hour
from here and then I was riding him last
February
I was countering him very very smart
also put him into counter from standing
still and I said to Ken wow he seems
frisky and I just had covered I hadn't
written him for about 10 days he'd been
ridden but I haven't he has a trainer
that you know like exercising right and
I said I'm just gonna go one more time
as you do and he bucked he reared I
stayed on and then he fell and we were
galloping
and I went over the top I damaged my
back luckily didn't break my back was
badly damaged here and my ribs and he
jumped over the top of me so I went over
the top of him he jumped over the top of
me thankfully and then realized he'd
done wrong you know because he'd put a
buck in the rear and never done that
with me before and he just stood there I
broke my leg in seven places I heard it
break well you've probably done that
millions of times right you put you hear
that break I'd never broken anything
before
yeah I had like um is actually okay now
it's like I've got a plate there
I've got two long uh pins and three
screws here so I broke it from here down
there seven places but yesterday when I
was getting my little ponies in I don't
know why I've made a little pony yeah
see that bruise there yeah yeah one of
them ran over my foot so normally I'd go
on the treadmill just a little baby
ponies
even a little baby pony is probably 200
pounds so yeah galloped around the the
fields yeah didn't you try and ride them
when you hear them
they're miniature horses but when they
want to do something yeah they are 10
times stronger than we are and he wanted
to get out the gate which I didn't end
up running around the property with us
chasing them but he ran over my foot so
yeah I normally do the treadmill for
about an hour but probably I need a day
off okay now the Beverly Hills
housewives of Beverly Hills help me
don't even get me started yes Steve what
is that it just it just continues on
it's a it's a force without me without
me oh yeah I left four years ago how
about this your audience is going to be
furious with me for my pitiful ignorance
no listen hey I'm fine with that I left
there's a cloud of dust behind me and uh
yeah I just did Watch What Happens Live
and I said Dandy you know thank you for
saying the door's always open he nodded
his head but
um no
you you watch it you continue to watch
it no I've never I didn't even see the
season I left in
I just left I just turned around I was
fed up with being accused of you know I
have my own spin-off really for seven
years prior to leaving and by the same
production company in the same network I
used to film at the same time I don't
know there were feelings about that
being given my own spin off with my name
on it
always the the wealthiest of the
Housewives is that I don't know about
that I mean there's but no but I I
was self-made and nobody gave me
anything but I'm sure there's some of
them I don't know you're the awesomest
yeah right okay
Steve oh says I was the awesomest
housewife and said they were all haters
well you said that but yeah you're right
um so they were constantly accuse me of
this or that in the end I was just like
I cannot do this anymore and then
actually honestly when I was
um my brother died in May
um and I would you'd start filming
Vanderpump Rules two days after his
funeral and it was really difficult for
me to do that but it's not a show so
much about my personal life and I kind
of said look
I really do not I cannot talk about this
I I was absolutely my only sibling I was
devastated I mean devastated
um
I I can't talk about it you know and uh
so I managed to get through Vanderpump
Rules coming to the end of that and they
said we want you to go back to
housewives in a couple of years I'd said
look I don't want to do this anymore I
don't want to be the target of you know
our courses reunions it'd be five
against one screaming at me I was just
like I can't do it I would open the
fridge and look for if milk was in the
fridge I'd cry you know I felt like very
you know kind of a whole situation
emotionally I was like on the edge a
little bit and they said no I want you
back and I just got like into a few
episodes and there was this situation
about this dog and they just kept coming
at me saying I would give a story to
some ridiculous outlet and I just said
no and I kept saying no to me when you
say to somebody I swear to your my
children's life that should be good now
especially around coming for somebody as
a you know believer religious and no I
don't believe you said you know what
[__] off I'm done don't get the [__] out
of my house I was done I was done and I
never went back they did ask me back and
they asked me to carry on filming I said
nope I'm halfway through the show I'm
not going back that was it drill on the
sand I am dead so I love the fact you
don't know I'm on it because that means
you don't watch it yeah but I love the
fact you knew all about Vanderpump Rules
I I I did see a video of uh it was not
gonna bring out any porno that I did no
no no no I've never done porno
they never found it no if it was there
they would find it it I saw a video the
title was uh Lisa Vanderpump just just
what was it called just tearing people
down or just like you know putting
people in their place like what was that
it's like a compilation it's a
compilation of you you're just letting
people have it all right okay well
that's probably about rules I think when
I remember when uh stassi came on stassi
was very you know she she like at least
at least you hate me she wanted her job
back and I remember I went you're not
important enough to hate sit down
I also heard uh the the part of it was
you saying I've never sold a story in my
life and I'm insulted by that yes yeah
yeah because to me my words is my bond
sure you know and if somebody a good
friend says to you I want to know and I
say if I say my hand to God or I swear
my children's life I think that should
be good enough for anybody yeah because
any good friend of mine if they ever
said that say a thousand percent I
believe you now let's figure it out you
know so for me just this constant
[__] accusations I was like no also
stories never ever came out of my
restaurant ever you know over the years
and I've seen everything I mean we've
carried people out the back a million
times you know it's not you but like
people said people sell their own
stories to the outlets I've never saw
the story because I've just always been
so dying to get it on TMZ that like it
never even occurred to me
can you give me an example of somebody's
telling a story
people sell stories all the time you can
be in a restaurant you could be talking
to somebody and they sell a story but
you know what this before I got to
emergency when I broke my leg as I say
in seven places I was put in the truck
and you couldn't have anybody go with
you I couldn't have Ken go with me
because covet right and so they were
like they put me in the truck and they
would go and cross the ground you know
it was really bumpy going my Lair class
just like God I knew I was just totally
screwed you know and so when I got to
emergency as I came you know they put me
on the trolley my phone rang TMZ they
got the story before I even got into
emergency I was like wow so I always
said to them how do you you know how do
you find that out is it paramedics is it
who tells you do you have you know
because they have a hot lunch Courthouse
or something like that if there's a
lawsuit or something and they said no
just somebody gave me a story I said can
you tell me how much you get paid for
you know giving your story they said oh
no we don't pay we don't pay unless
there are pictures or there weren't any
pictures so what's the point of giving
somebody I don't get the whole thing I
don't get it but yeah I think people
just want to feel like they're in the
know and just I think it's it's a like a
logistical like conundrum of once you've
told somebody the story or given them
the asset like what leverage do you have
now they know yeah
God says how do you negotiate a price
for something that they don't know and
then once they do know oh I see once
they do know how they know how that
works actually good point
I've got something yeah how are you
going to give me but as he said he
didn't he said no we don't give money
unless there are pictures so maybe
that's when you I honestly don't know if
somebody like radar online I mean I
don't know I really don't know maybe
then if you've got the picture yeah yeah
the stereotypical moment of like handing
the briefcase and like taking the
hostage yeah
yeah I don't know I mean you're lovely
and and I love to consider you a friend
oh you know what I love that about you
and I do consider you a friend and
you're such a good friend you're
actually going to come to my vanderbump
dog Foundation garlic when is it it's uh
May the 18th it's kind of sold out so
you have you have to come with my guess
I will be back from my next Australia
tour oh when are you going there either
I I believe I'm back on May 11th okay
great so I can sleep for a week okay
sure yeah well it's all about the dogs
we haven't had the gala for
um three years now because of covert
Mario Lopez who's one of the kindest
people on the planet do you know Mario
I've met him a bunch of times
so nice decent no drama we always just
said besides of course I want to hosted
such a great charity let me do this and
like so calm and easy just so he'll be
hosting it we'll have just some great
people there it's a lot of fun everybody
does dress up don't come in your T-shirt
come inside okay like you know I enjoy
dressing up bring your wife yeah yeah
it's dressed up and it's a fabulous site
and you know whatever we raise it all
goes to the dogs and we take on in our
foundation you know situations that
nobody dogs in China yeah well we have a
sanctuary in China but you know we take
on a lot of hopeless cases that you know
otherwise the dog would be euthanized
you know like and so Vanderpump dog
Foundation if anybody's interested in it
goes to vandervumpdogs.org my Gala is
sold out now even though it's not for a
couple of months it's I think people you
know have always been amazing in terms
of supporting it but we have just great
sponsors
um you know Caesar's Palace sponsors uh
jsx I don't know if you know yeah we fly
tomorrow on them oh okay they are
brilliant jet sweet the best model in
fact there's a picture of me on the side
of the plane with dogs on one of their
planes because they support the van of
Hump dog Foundation I've seen that brand
grow jet Suite X is it's such a
brilliant model you know of the way they
kind of it makes travel so much easier I
I love them I mean they just they're and
also you can take your dog with you
easily you know you can buy a seat next
to you or a small dog on but very easily
um we just got a lot of great supporters
you know people love our four-legged
furry friends and I think now
domestically we've adopted and found
good homes for I think about 2 800 dogs
just in L.A County
um and then we go out like as I say
we've been involved in Peru and Mexico
and all different you know we go to
disaster relief and you know we try and
help with animals we have a homeless
program that we work with you know a lot
of homeless people have dogs that need
span neutering and vaccination and then
we have
um a veterans program where we've
trained dogs to be you know PTSD dogs so
there's a lot of things and we fought
against the yulin dog meat yeah so I did
a
documentary which actually yes it is
hard to watch a lot of it but you know
when people say oh I can't I can't walk
away if I looked away and I love dogs
more than people I worship their little
Furry Paws that you know walk on I just
we can't look away in life sometimes it
has to cause you pain for you to be
motivated to do something different and
so we've been really active we marched
to the Embassy we did Congress I did go
to Congress thank you resolution 401
yeah it was to end the dog meat trade
put it in the Diplomatic portfolio so
that's yeah to condemn the dog meat
trade
um we have fought against China and
really drawn attention we did a a
documentary as well that's on Amazon and
it was just a fight and we keep going
and we've drawn a lot of attention to it
you should go to China when the Dogmeat
uh Festival is on you should go with a
baseball bat and like God actually I
shouldn't be inciting violence but you
should go and protest I mean it's just
so horrifying the fact that this dog
Festival in China that they're they're
if I understand correctly the idea is to
eat the media the dog and that some they
they believe that the more fear and pain
that the dog experiences that the the
more valuable the dog's meat is is that
I well what if you I mean the
documentary as I say is it it I called
and where did people find it uh the road
to yulin Beyond yeah
yeah it's um
we've shed so many tears over it you
know I've seen Ken Ken was thrown off
Twitter a few times when he you would
ever see you know some images so he'd be
like I'm gonna you know like he really
reacted very kind of where's this
documentary available on Amazon yeah
Amazon yeah and um it was just it was
something that really motivated us to
try and make a difference I believed I
have a platform and I do believe that if
you're a celebrity and you have all
these kind of you know unbelievable
gestures and privileges bestowed upon
you and of course there's a lot of
things that are hard to deal with as
well you know stories that aren't true
that people like right you know there's
a lot of that we know that's difficult
to do with but you have a social
responsibility to draw attention to some
you know for the greater good so for me
it was always you know suicide
prevention of lgbtq issues it was the
the dogs and that was just something I
believed is the a way of giving back I
mean we used to feed the Homeless from
one of my restaurants fill a blanket
that closed down for 12 years every week
every week we'd cook food and take it
before Housewives before this you know I
believe everybody has it doesn't matter
what you do it doesn't matter if you
can't afford to even if you do one
little thing it's just like even with
donations you know even if it's a dollar
donation like sometimes we'll actually
do dollar donations we'll have a
hopeless case a dog left on the side of
the road or needs you know it's it's a
lot of work but I've got incredible
group of people people volunteer people
dedicate their lives for the love of
dogs so yeah without them we we couldn't
do anything yeah do you like the way
that the dogs Paws smell
uh I don't really sniff the paws I sniff
the ears never but yeah I just love them
I just think they're they're so smart as
well people don't realize how smart they
are people like their sense of smell
what they can detect and they're they're
just incredible you know listen I love
all animals
um I'm kind of vegetarian I eat for the
chicken but apart from that I'm like
yeah I haven't eaten any meat other than
Seafood for over
14 years that's really good yeah I I
just have such an iron deficiency and I
in anemic so many times I thought okay
I'm gonna try and eat a little bit right
but uh yeah and and I love the fact I
love people that love dogs I love you
see a certain kindness in people you
know the way they treat their animals
and uh yeah it was very devastating to
see what goes on the yulin dog meat
first of all and there was a lot of you
know where they would boil the dogs
alive and you see these dogs trying to
clamber out of pots or you see them hang
up and beaten with a baseball bat I mean
just terrible terrible terrible videos
um so yeah it's been a lot of heartbreak
over that but you know life's about what
you do and making a difference isn't it
so we just do what we can and that's you
know I love that okay so we're gonna
send everybody to watch the road to
yulon on Amazon yeah yeah some of it's
It's hard to watch I
but I think education is what is your
own motivation you know and you know
whether or not you watch the road to you
lawn maybe if you feel that you can't
stomach you can absolutely donate to
band of hump dogs to org yeah
but even if it's like look at our
missions and what we do
um you know as I say it's been hard it's
actually been hard keeping the
foundation going I'm A working woman you
know how I made a lot of money for my
Foundation because when covert hit I
thought how are we going to keep this
going all our restaurants are closed
I've got all these dogs got the
sanctuary in China what am I going to do
how am I going to keep this like funding
this Foundation when our businesses are
all shut down
so Lance Vaz very good friend of mine
have you ever had him on here
um I have not had Lance basketball you
will love him okay great great great
great guy I'm godmother to his children
very kind of a lot of fun but very kind
he actually they do a lot of fostering
and they've had dogs helped us with our
dogs for years
but he said to me oh have you ever done
Cameo and I was like No And so he said
oh you should do Cameo he said I do
Cameo and he donates some of the
Charities so I thought okay I'm gonna
set up cameo
um and I'm going to donate all the money
from Cameo to my dog Foundation I don't
care how many cameos I do I'm going to
do literally as many you know that come
in if I can
well now I've been on it like since
covid 398
000 later that's how many cameos I've
done and that's kind of been apart from
fundraising and us giving money
personally just kept one of the things
that kept it going and it was tenacious
it was ambitious I keep going I still do
it as I do as many as I can but all the
money goes to the dogs yeah that's great
yeah it's cool yeah I love it and it's
another reason why I love you oh right
back at you all right so um and and
Instagram and stuff you're you're on all
the social media yeah Lisa Vanderpump I
mean
and Vanderpump dogs has their own
Instagram you see what we do but um
mine's kind of like it's Visual and it's
pretty yeah it's good yeah and I've just
I keep doing what I love and you know
and just keep moving forward I I love it
and I love you thank you thank you thank
you very much all right good deal yeah
that really was wonderful oh you're so
sweet thank you and um let me see you
I'm gonna go let me give you my numbers
yeah we never again yeah oh that's my
girl how about that did I tell you we
were buddies or what and I'll have you
know that after this she said let's have
dinner just uh you know me and Lux
invited to dinner by Lisa Vanderpump I'm
so taking her up on that
um I love her man she's the best and I
love you for sticking around to the end
of the Wild Ride podcast and if any of
uh the new people who just came for Lisa
Vanderpump this is a thing that we do at
the Wild Ride podcast
I express my gratitude to those of you
who stick around to the end and I say
hey man if you really enjoyed this then
go ahead and post a screenshot of the
podcast on whatever device you're
consuming it and post that screenshot
tagging my guest Lisa Vanderpump and let
her know that you enjoyed the podcast I
always love it if my guests see it
online the people are getting giving
positive feedback it makes them feel
good about having done the Wild Ride
podcast and uh it's just a good vibe man
and whenever I see those posts man I
like and I comment to show my gratitude
to you so putting that out there the
people who do that I call the street
team the wild ride street team and
they're my favorite people in the world
and that is you thank you so much